hey it's Evan and today I mention a
question from one of my YouTube viewers
Ronnie Ronnie thank you so much for
writing in love you YouTube guys
Ronnie wrote in to say how do I stop all
the spam on my wordpress blog it's so
time-consuming to delete and find that
I've stopped posting because it just
opens up the door for more spam and I
don't have time to devote to cleanup I
must be missing something
Sheila should be this time consuming
difficult frustrated Ronnie I feel your
pain I went through the same thing and
you know what the more popular your blog
gets the more spam you're gonna get I
mean that's one of the price of being
popular
I guess I've dealt with it a few ways
and hopefully you can learn I'm gonna
share with you some of the things that I
do that that you can leverage so I'm
gonna load up my blog this is my is my
back-end on the blog you can see I've
had 3,400 posts 34,000 comments 31,000
are approved 2200 are spam and if I go
to my comments for the most part they're
pretty good so there's some comments
that have come in if I look at what's
pending there's a few some of these
still do require some manual approving
so high event so a few people seem to
realize they've overcome
they've already overcome the biggest
risk so know Gary has provided some
great comment here on the post so I can
approve that this one my brother and
Friends recommended I am like this
website this is where I'm kind of on the
fence because English is not the first
language and this doesn't look like a
spammy comment but you know do I approve
it or not I usually make a judgment call
this one he's just trying to add to the
conversation even though the English
isn't perfect it's not a spam you know
we used a real email account so I to
prove that but if I look in my spam
folder you'll see thousands and these
get deleted I want to say every 30 days
against anything in my spam folder just
gets deleted so it doesn't get doesn't
add up and add up and add up what you'll
find is a mix of people people who will
try to post something that's kind of
related you know nice articles but then
if you look at it it's uggs glove and
it's some you know spammy website here
that's showing up I have to check every
now and then to see you know what the
wetter is in here too because this one
might work you know very
true you gotta take some chances this
one doesn't look like it's a spam
I don't know Alfred real estate but it
relates to this topic so I could say not
spam as an example and that one could be
posted and then you get some that are
just totally you know flat-out spam like
what the heck is this I don't know what
whatever this thing is and you know
spammy late website and and it'll just
get removed so having great spam filters
is definitely a great way to do it and
how I built it up there's a couple
things that can help you the first is
having the plug-in and you should
already have a queue Smet this is the
main one that I use and WordPress
usually comes with this by default and
this has a great job of eliminating the
spam you need to sign up for an accurate
API key always make sure that this is
up-to-date so whenever this says that
it's out of date go get the newest
version because it does most of the
heavy lifting for me in limiting the
spam that comes in so you definitely
want to update this and then beyond you
can also edit your settings so in
discussion here some of the settings
that I have here are I don't approve
every comment manually and I don't get
an email to me all the time but I find
these two ones are really important so
if somebody has already had a comment
that's been approved before then it'll
get post it'll be approved again I'm
assuming that somebody has done a good
job in commenting before they're gonna
do a good job ongoing so a little bit a
trust factor there usually spammers
don't have great comments and then
crappy comments they just start right
away with the crop so that's why I have
this checked off so if they've already
approved the comment then they get in
the next time and maybe by showing this
I'm opening myself up to a lot of spam
anyway the other one is if somebody has
three links or more in their post and it
gets flagged as well so it doesn't get
automatically post it as a comment it'll
get held for moderation those are the
two things that come up and I find that
these settings on with keeping our key
smite up-to-date really helped me the
last thing I do is I do not usually do a
lot of the comment filtering myself I've
set up somebody on my team and her
responsibility is to go through the
comments and approve the ones that are
good to let me know if I need to respond
to some of them so I can approve this
one here that we just took off
and so I don't do this myself and you
can set that up easily you can have
under users you can set up other people
to come on so here's your user option
you can add a new user and you can set
up a virtual assistant to come in even
if it's once a day to go in and approve
comments and just move the other ones to
spam I could save you a lot of time and
help you focus on the bigger picture
worst case if it's still bogging you
down you don't want to you know spend
the you know a couple bucks an hour
whatever it is to hire somebody to do
that for you and it's still causing a
lot of problems for you I would then
just eliminate comments because I don't
want it to hold you back from writing
writing this so important it's getting
your opinion out there you have content
that could be shared and you're you're
sharing your voice with the world and
it's so critical because you need
word-of-mouth marketing to promote your
business so if it's the comments that
are holding you back this has worked for
me and again I've had I forget how many
comments what did I say 30 30 1000
approved comments so I've got a lot of
comments that I've had to sort through
and for the most part these two tools
work for me but if you're still finding
that it's just too overwhelming and you
can't have somebody help you with it
then just eliminate comments but make
sure that you keep writing because it is
so important for your business so
hopefully this has helped you can see
here our concern is protecting me from
almost half a million spam comments
already so it's got a ton of spam as
well and I know it's a frustrating
problem but hopefully it doesn't hold
you back from continuing with your blog
believe those are you watching liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
love to hear if you're fighting spam
with another way that I haven't
discovered yet and share it with me and
share it with Ronnie as well if you guys
liked the video thumbs up if you have a
comment let me know question let me know
feedback below I'll make a video
response thank you so much and I'll see
you soon